- I've had people that
find out I'm a stripper,
and they're just like, "How
do you do that and be a mom?"
I'm like, "I just am a mom,
what do you do when you go to work?"
Someone who works in the
ER and they see things
that children shouldn't see,
that doesn't affect their children, right?
It might affect them, and
I'm sure we deal with stuff
that affects us on a personal level,
but you put it together
like every other parent,
and you do your parenting duties,
and you come home and you
kiss boo boos and you cuddle.
(dubstep music)
My name is Lexy, I'm 26 years old,
and I'm a stripper.
So, I was in kind of a financial bind.
I was out a lot of money right
after I had my second baby,
and I needed a job quick,
so I traded a baby carrier
for a pair of stripper heels,
literally, to a friend.
I auditioned at a club and I got a job.
And I've been in love with it since,
because I love the money I can make.
I've never had a conflict
morally with parenting
and dancing, at all.
I got pregnant with my
daughter when I was 19,
I had her when I was 20,
and I just fell in love with mothering.
I've homeschooled her forever.
Being a mom is number
one, it's everything,
and it's really, it
motivates it all, obviously.
I wanna be able to buy my
kids Christmas presents,
and take them to Disney World,
and you know, just do anything for them.
If my kid needed a tutor, or
to go to a private school,
I wanna be able to do that,
and I feel like it really
improves my kids' quality of life.
Money gives you opportunity.
I don't care what people
say about happiness,
but it gives you opportunity,
and that's really important for me.
Christmas is always a big holiday.
I make family vacations in Disney Land,
and Christmas a really big deal,
and it's really how I know how to express
to my kids that I love them,
and I want them to have something magical,
like memories, I want them to feel loved,
I want them to remember a big
beautiful tree, and presents.
When my family has ever
criticized what I do,
or they're like, "I wish
you wouldn't do it."
They'll claim it's about my safety,
but I tell them that, "If you
really want me to be safe,
what you do in your everyday life,
is don't let people make
jokes about strippers,
don't let people talk
about us like we're not
human beings, or when you hear
that a stripper has been murdered,
don't let other people
say, 'oh well you know,
she's kinda asking for it.'
Don't make excuses for dehumanization,
and our violence, you know what I mean?
That's what's gonna make us safe overall,
is by changing how people view us."
I have definitely
experience being outside,
spending time with people,
and them just assuming
that since I'm a dancer,
that I'm more sexual,
or I'm gonna do something for them,
or I just really like it,
I just really wanna take my clothes
off for them or something.
The first night I ever
danced I was assaulted.
Like, I had a guy try to put a dollar bill
inside of me while I was on stage,
that's how he thought he was gonna tip me.
Like I said, like, jokes
and stuff like that
contributes to people
feeling like we want it,
it's cool, it's what it is, you know,
as opposed to, this is
a paid place situation,
and every girl has different boundaries.
My daughter knows that I dance,
she knows that I work at a club,
she knows that I go on stage
and do tricks on a pole.
When she asks why she
can't come and see me work,
I tell her it's because
they serve alcohol,
so it's not for children.
She has no concept of a lap dance,
or anything like that.
I like to be open,
because I'm not ashamed,
and I want her to know, I don't
want her to be embarrassed.
I want her to hear from me, you know,
what I do and what's going on,
so that if one day somebody's like,
"Your mom's a stripper?"
She's like, "Yeah, she's athletic,
she's beautiful, she's
confident, she's hardworking.
My mom's a stripper, for sure."
It's just about providing for them.
It's just about giving them
the life I think they deserve,
which is everything and more.
As I be able to give them more,
I want them also to
understand that other people
don't have that, and the
hard work that it takes,
and let that be the perspective,
the lens that they see it through.